ماك أليسون ، هذا تمامًا بدون
السوابق التاريخية الأخيرة التي مفادها أن
الملكة يجب أن تقضي إجازتها في
اسكتلندا من قبل رئيس الوزراء
يطلب منها تعليق عمل البرلمان ،
والسبب في أنه يُنظر إلى
أن بوريس جونسون يفعل هذا تمامًا
لأنه يريد التخلص من المعارضة في
البرلمان من حزبه
ومن أحزاب المعارضة الذين يريدون
منعه من
الخروج من الاتحاد الأوروبي بدون صفقة خروج
دون اتفاق متفقًا على ما
حدث أمس في لندن كان
اجتماعًا لجميع أحزاب المعارضة
وقرروا هناك أنهم  لن يكون لديهم
تصويت بحجب الثقة عن حكومة بوريس جونسون
ومحاولة إسقاط
حكومته بدلاً من ذلك سيجدون
آلية قانونية في البرلمان لمنع
أي اتفاق يخرقها ، ما استيقظ بوريس جونسون
وفعله اليوم هو تجنب
ذلك بالتعليق  البرلمان وأساسًا
لا يمنح البرلمان الوقت الكافي
للنقاش والتوصل إلى صيغة قانونية
وإطار عمل  توقف عن عدم وجود صفقة
استراحة سمعناها من
رئيس مجلسي البرلمان
سمعناهما من
وزير الخزانة الأخير كلاهما يقول إن هذا أمر
شائن ما يفعله بوريس جونسون ويصفه
نواب المعارضة بأنه شائن
أنهم  وصفها بوريس جونسون بأنها خطيرة
من ناحية أخرى ، فهي
تتمسك بأسلحتها وتقول إن البرلمان
لا يزال لديه ما يكفي من الوقت لمناقشة
خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي ، وسيكون هناك متسع من الوقت على كلا
الجانبين في أكتوبر / تشرين الأول الحاسم للقمة السابعة عشرة
في البرلمان
لكي يناقش النواب مسألة خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي.  خروج الاتحاد الأوروبي من الاتحاد الأوروبي وجميع
القضايا الأخرى متسع من الوقت ، هذا
بدون سوابق تاريخية حديثة ،
وهذا يعمق من خطوط المعركة حول
خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الأوروبي ، نحن حقًا في
منطقة مجهولة هنا ، وهذا سوف يسبب
ويخلق غضبًا كبيرًا وعداءًا ضخمًا
سيجلس البرلمان مرة أخرى بعد ذلك.  تم
تعليق الأسبوع في الأسبوع الذي يليه